the writer of an original screenplay has
only himself to please or to blame
whereas the writer who adapts existing
material also tries to please the author
of the novel the play the short story or
the suicide note and as well as that all
writers have to please their producers
and their directors their stars their
studio executives distributors
exhibitors publicists and merchandisers
all of whom have to stick their two
cents in the audience gets to put their
seven dollars and 52 cents in the
nominees for Best Screenplay based on
material previously produced or
published our J Cox and Martin Scorsese
for the age of innocence based on the
novel by Edith Wharton Terry George and
Jim Sheridan for in the name of the
Father
based on the autobiographical book
proved innocent by Gerry Conlon Ruth
Prabhu job Miller for the remains of the
day based on the novel by Kazuo Ishiguro
Steve Zaillian for Schindler's List
based on the nonfiction book by Thomas
Keneally William Nicholson for
Shadowlands based on his stage play and
the Oscar goes to Steven Zaillian
fashion business
I owe this to my father who who believed
completely in the thing that destroyed
Oskar Schindler is a businessman common
decency
I want to thank him the rest of my
family Steven Spielberg and I'd like to
accept this in honor of the 1,200
survivors of Schindler's factory and
their families and in memory of those
whose names are not on Schindler's List
thank you very very much